I've just been told to reminds you that
all winners are asked to go into the
press room and line up in alphabetical
order from left to right to have their
pictures taken for the British
newspapers and then line up right to
left for the Israeli papers
our next award is for editing and it'll
be presented by two stars who never fail
to give winning performances miss Lee
Remick
who is a beautiful girl and mr. James
Stewart on loan up from the Air Force
oh this is an exciting night isn't it
Jimmy ah yeah yeah yes well now now
let's say Li worship we're supposed to
do something here yes we're to honor
those artists who after the writing was
written and the director directed and
the actor has acted controls the final
destiny of our work I'm not gonna do it
I'm not gonna give any award to any
movie creditors Oh
I'll film at it as well if we didn't
have that it is we wouldn't have any
movies Oh Phil matters well whether for
the best achievement in film editing the
nominees are
William be murky for fantastic voice
Frederick Stan camp Henry Berman Stewart
Linda and Frank Santa low for Grand Prix
how Ashbury and Jade Terry Williams for
the Russians are coming the Russians are
coming
William Reynolds for the sand pebbles
and Sam Osteen for Who's Afraid of
Virginia Woolf no I'll open this thing
Lee and then you would you would take
and read the winner
all right the winners are Frederick
Stine camp Henry Berman Stuart Linder
and Frank sent widow for prom freak
we'd like to thank you the members of
the Academy the very talented technical
people at MGM and the greatest film
editing staff ever assembled
thank you